let's return now to our exclusive
interview with jewel lab CEO Kevin burns
he acknowledged that we do not know the
long-term effects of vaping when you
were considering this job you took it in
2017 as I understand it your daughter 16
didn't want you to take it my 15 at the
time she was worried she did not know
much about the product and the company
and she was worried what the company
focused was and what the product was she
was a teenager at the time she was
already familiar with it didn't that
tell you something my teenage daughter
doesn't represent the 1.1 billion
smokers around the world though she has
no exposure to smokers we live in a
community where has very few smokers in
a very low smoking rate so for me I
looked at the opportunity to have a huge
impact on the number one source of
preventable death in the world which is
getting people off of cigarettes I said
that's a massive public health
opportunity and our doctor Tara Narula
is here to break down what we do know
about e-cigarettes doctor good morning
there's a lot to chew over in this
conversation what jumped out to you well
I think what jumps out to me is the
issues with the lung disease that we're
seeing that we reported on last week you
know we've talked a lot about the
effects of e-cigarettes on the brain in
a youth population affecting attention
and learning and memory the
cardiovascular effects and I think a lot
of these are intangible for parents and
kids to wrap their mind around their
sort of long-term problems but when you
see a child intubated on a ventilator
suddenly this becomes very real and very
scary and I think this is really a
wake-up call for every parent listening
to this story today to get up and have a
conversation with their kids today
tomorrow this weekend about vaping you
can argue the merits for you know
smokers to help them quit but nobody is
saying that this has value or benefit in
a youth population so you see this as a
call to action for parents I would
should they know about the toxicity what
what do you want them to know I think
they need to know that when I spoke to
dr. Chapman yesterday in Minnesota they
said that they're seeing these pattern
of inhalation injury that looks similar
and all the kids who are presenting kids
who previously had no lung disease who
were healthy ages 15 to 23 who suddenly
have shortness of breath chest pain
flu-like symptom
and within a day's to a week are ending
up on oxygen on a ventilator now many of
them have been discharged but the
question is what is the long-term
ramifications what are the long-term
ramifications going to be to the lungs
in these don't even know ter that their
kids are vaping that story that was in
the news recently the parents were
shocked as her son is in a coma
medically induced coma that he was even
vaping so parents feed to make
themselves aware of vaping right we can
no longer avoid this it needs to be part
of our understanding we need to know the
facts about what the problems are so we
can explain that to our kids we need to
know what the vaping device is exactly
it can look like a pen a USB a lot a lot
of them can be easily concealed they
don't have a lot of vapor so parents
need to be on the lookout for that and
they really need to be having frank open
conversations with their kids starting
very early as early as kindergarten now
some of the teams who've gotten sick
have reported using THC in these vapors
vaporizers is that part of the problem
that products that are not necessarily
Joule products they're not necessarily
nicotine are being put into these
devices that absolutely could be part of
the problem but we really don't know yet
you know the state health officials the
CDC the FDA are all on this right now
because they're seeing this flood of
cases throughout the country and we
really do need to figure out what
exactly it is but in the meantime the
reality is whatever it is it needs to be
something that's avoided in a youth
population that device on the table
there that Joule it actually belongs to
Linda who's in hair and makeup we did my
amazing waves is an adult an adult
smoker who is now Midway to switching
and she's trying to use Joule to help
her she was saying this morning that she
hears the reports of these lung
illnesses she hears our coverage of it
and it makes her worry and she pushes
her back toward cigarettes so there's
kind of two messages here there's the
teen message within the adult message
what is the message to grownups you were
hearing this what do they do
should they switch should they not you
know I think we need more research and
we've said this before and we're getting
more research there was just a study
that came out in February looking at
East cigarettes versus a traditional
nicotine replacement therapy and which
might be better to help smokers quit and
it may be the down the road we have
proof that these are actually beneficial
but right now as far as what is
amended it is not one of the recommended
ways we have the gum the patch other
medications counseling but I don't think
anybody can say that it doesn't
potentially have value for current
smokers but that's the that's one issue
as you said and what I really want to
focus on when I think we really need to
focus on is the youth population because
yeah what about all the people when
people when young people do things they
often do them together so what about
teenagers who might be around vapors
inhaling that vapor because he's only
been out for 11 years really on the
market not only do we not have long-term
research on what the effects are on you
if you use e-cigarettes down the road
are you gonna develop cancer or other
problems we don't have Larissa's
research really on the secondhand smoke
effects but you it would make sense
logically that if you're inhaling
something that someone else is using and
you're close by certainly you could be
exposed to whatever those chemicals are
well you say your concern is about the
teenagers it does seem like people like
the Joule mr. burns that they are now
trying to dial it back on how they were
marketing to teenagers they say they
never were marketing to teenagers but
that's hard to believe when you look at
some of the advertisements but it seems
like they're now trying to dial that
back and make it hard and very difficult
for teens to now get it right and I
think that's a great thing you know
unfortunately now we're you know five or
six years into this problem and so I
think until jewel is able to implement
what it's trying to do until the FDA
really gets its hands around this issue
that's why I think parents and schools
and health care professionals need to be
on the front lines of this parents need
to recognize signs that their kid might
be by using for instance are they yep
for instance are they going outside or
to the bathroom during family gatherings
do you smell a sweet odor on their
clothes or in their room that they're
maybe trying to conceal with air
freshener are they complaining of being
thirsty having nosebleeds being
irritable or anxious those are all
resources or you're finding stuff in
their room that you don't really know
what it is it looks like some strange
technology devices or cords or chargers
thank you dr. Narula
I think I think parents really want to
hear is the people responsible for the
early Joule ads those colorful ones
Kevin Burns tells me none of those
people work for the company anymore so
on the question of how they turn a page
they've changed the team yeah they're
taking steps well
thank you so much for all that insight
and all those terrors well parent of two
young children I got it this will get
barrier to the break